[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cooking is about using
your senses and intuition.
You don't need measuring cups.
This is your measuring cup.
One cup, two cup.
[LAUGHS]
I'm a Korean-American
LA kid, immigrant kid,
but the food that I cook
is American, you know?
I was raised here.
There are a lot of things that I
won't teach you in this class--
exact measurements, exact
volume, precise cuts.
I really believe in wiggle room.
[LAUGHS]
I like to wiggle.
We had this truck,
we had Twitter,
and it was an opportunity
to just cook the food
that we wanted to cook.
We didn't know it was going
to start a revolution.
Told you I'm not going to
show you the kogi taco,
but I'm actually showing
you the kogi taco.
[BLEEP]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this class, I'm
going to teach you
how to make my mother sauces--
kimchi, panchan, the
kimchi tuna melt,
carnitas, mung bean
potato scallion pancakes.
If you don't look like Dexter
by the time you finish making
kimchi, you didn't do it right.
A lot of times you'll see in
recipes, use only the leaves.
Discard the stems.
Erase all that bullshit
from your mind.
Use the whole vegetable.
What's the worst
that could happen?
It's going to taste better?
Yeah.
Now this is what you
came to MasterClass for.
Look at this.
Growing up as a young
kid here in Los Angeles,
it was very tough
Monday through Friday
for a lot of immigrant families.
We were made fun of and bullied.
We had to just do whatever
we had to do to survive.
But the weekends were for us.
The weekends are when we
used to go to the park
and everyone would bring kalbi
and short rib to the party.
And I swear, when you
put this on the grill,
you can't stop
people from eating it
before it hits the table.
I want to teach you a lot
about instinct, about feel,
about seeing things, hearing
things, smelling things.
To me, that's really cooking.
You didn't learn how
to make a recipe.
You learned how to cook.
It will live with you forever.
I will live with you
forever and you'll never
be able to get rid of me.
I'm Roy Choi, and
this is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]